it was just last year that we reached
100,000 living alumni of the university
in more than 100 countries with this
commencement ceremony with you
graduating today we begin CMU's march
toward 200,000 living alumni when I
called her Louis to be our commencement
speaker this year at several months ago
he asked me what should he talk about I
said he can talk about whatever he
chooses to talk about we never compared
notes I had no idea until he started to
speak what he was going to talk about
and he had no idea what I'm going to say
now it's all good it turns out that we
are approaching the same same theme from
very different angles unbeknownst to
each other we were focusing on a similar
theme early this year a group of CMU
faculty members and I traveled to
Switzerland to attend the World Economic
Forum in Davos for this meeting which
attracts world leaders technologists
industry leaders policymakers writers
filmmakers performance and the global
media the World Economic Forum chose the
theme the fourth Industrial Revolution
the first Industrial Revolution which
started in the late 18th century created
mechanization specifically according to
one perspective from the World Economic
Forum it was the Year 1784 and the
catalyst for this revolution were steam
water and mechanical production
equipment a major outcome of this
revolution was the emergence of
industrialized cities
we're some form of human or animal labor
could be replaced by mechanical labor
each revolution created more advanced
forms of manufacturing and altered the
global economy in unprecedented and
irreversible ways the Second Industrial
Revolution which started in the late
19th century created mass production the
catalyst for this revolution considered
to have begun in 1870 where the division
of labor electricity and mass production
a major outcome of this revolution was
the emergence of industrialized regions
and economies of scale the third
Industrial Revolution which started in
the late 20th century created
unprecedented automation the catalyst
for this revolution considered to have
begun in 1969 where micro electronics
information and communication
technologies the internet robotics and
automation a major outcome of this
revolution was the emergence of global
production networks and the input costs
were significantly altered the fourth
Industrial Revolution which many leaders
who were gathered at the World Economic
Forum focused on is believed to be
occurring now in the early part of the
21st century although no one is quite
sure when exactly it began in my view
what makes the fourth Industrial
Revolution unlike the previous three
stems from at least a few key factors
the speed of change the role of the
individual citizen of the world
whether he or she is educated or
uneducated is rich or poor lives in a
developed country or a developing
country he or she can engage in a
two-way communication at the cutting
edge of the fourth Industrial Revolution
at lightning speed individual
empowerment scale in which the
individual can do enormous good and
equally enormous harm the scope of
change the impact of that scope of
change on the global system intended
versus unintended consequences known
unknowns and unknown unknowns you are
graduating at a particularly exciting
time with the convergence of
technologies and human interactions with
those technologies is creating new
possibilities and new challenges new
solutions to problems and new threats
that create major new problems in many
domains of day-to-day life on the one
hand the convergence of the digital
physical and biological worlds is
generating unprecedented questions and
concerns about how governments and
individuals will address such issues as
employment income levels equality ethics
security policy confidentiality social
justice taxation diplomacy and global
interactions
at the same time the intersections of
the real and virtual worlds on the tug
of war between natural and artificial
intelligence or creating interesting
questions about the ways in which the
21st century will unfold during your
lifetime in your careers say 50 years
from now Earl Lewis talked about the
next 25 years
whether we emerge as better human beings
or not we'll critically depend on how
you shape the fourth Industrial
Revolution how you use our abuse the
tools at your disposal intentionally or
unintentionally nobody is better
prepared to shape the world than today's
graduates of Carnegie Mellon University
CMU faculty students and staff played a
pivotal role in their pioneering work
that enabled many of the technologies
that are critical to the fourth
Industrial Revolution computers and
computing robotics mobile communications
big data deep learning science of
learning artificial intelligence human
machine interactions tools for
cybersecurity and the Internet of Things
CMU has purposefully emphasized to you
during the course of your education here
the importance of connecting the
sciences engineering business and
technologies with human creativity in
the arts humanities social behavioral
and decision sciences and policy CMU's
own dr. Herbert Simon Nobel
prize-winning pioneering professor said
in 1971 a wealth of information creates
a poverty of attention to paraphrase it
differently the wealth of information
can create sometimes enormous confusion
between what earl liu is called garbage
and the real stuff
nobody is better prepared than you to
use a wealth of information deliberately
using careful thought reflection and
evidence to address major societal
problems our five honorary degree
candidates or role models in that
important connection between
technologies and the human condition
that will unfold in the coming years and
decades Holly Hunter and Sonia Manzano
used their beginnings at CMU to excel in
the arts and the entertainment world and
Sony has skillfully combined
entertainment and education to inspire
young minds Bob Langer is a pioneering
engineer whose work at the intersections
of engineering science and medicine
shaped new technologies our own alumnus
Jim Schwartz excelled in creating new
business opportunities economic value
and societal impact on a global scale
for those kinds of rapidly emerging
technologies Earl Lewis with a keen eye
and knowledge of history used the past
to shape the present and the future by
applying his intellect and energy to
expand diversity in academia to connect
the digital world with the humanities
and through his leadership roles in
academia and nonprofits as many have
said and I as I have said before that
some of the greatest technological
achievements of the 20th century have
played a major role in creating some of
the toughest Grand Challenges of the
21st century as CMU graduates and global
citizens you have exceptional talent and
unique cross disciplinary perspectives
that will enable you to face and address
these tough problems without creating
new challenges for the next revolution
my congratulations to you to your
families and friends and my enormous
gratitude to you for sharing your time
with us during the past few years
congratulations
you